The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: In this
evening lecture what
I'd like to do is continue a
bit to expand on and complicate
and maybe also
deepen this idea I've
been suggesting to you that
I'm labeling the Fred Ott
principle.
Really a shorthand
way of describing
the immensely complex-- and
from an intellectual standpoint,
a historical
standpoint-- immensely
exciting and astonishing
process whereby
film went in an
incredibly short time
from being a mere
novelty to being
an embedded social formation
in the United States
and in other
industrialized societies.
And not just only a
embedded social formation,
becoming by the end
of the 1920s one
of the central media for
the expression of art,
and an artistic medium.
So that he went from
being a mere novelty,
from Fred Ott's Sneeze in
20 years or so, 25 years,
to being a medium of
astonishingly rich and complex
narrative art.
That progress is part of what I
mean by the Fred Ott principle.
And it might be helpful if I
concretize that a little bit
more by mentioning a bit more
about what I mean about what
I was implying or
referring to when I spoke
about that moment of imitation.
Remember I said that
there were essentially--
that the silent film--
and incidentally,
I take it as a model for the
way in which most new media
systems develop in culture.
You can apply this
same basic schema
to other forms of
popular entertainment,
including-- shocking
as it may seem--
Shakespeare's public theater.
And I'll come back to the
implications of that analogy.
The idea that Shakespeare
was the movie of his time.
That Shakespeare's theater was
the Hollywood studio system
of the Elizabethan era.
It's a very complicated one.
It's a very inspiring one.
And it's complicated because it
makes us reassess our inherited
notions about what art is,
and where art comes from.
One of the subtexts
in this course
is precisely that, it has
to do with what I call
the enabling conditions of art.
And I'll come back to that again
as a theme, again and again
in the course.
So part of what I mean
by the Fred Ott principle
is this roiling complex,
partly unpredictable process,
whereby an enlarging
population incredibly
hungry for the novelties being
produced by this new technology
create a kind of
symbiotic relationship
between the audience
and the emerging medium.
So that as the medium grows
more complicated, in part
because the audience--
OK, after 5, or 10, or 15
visits to the Nickelodeon,
or-- after the movies moved out
of the penny arcades, and began
to take their own space as some
of you know, and
as it's recounted
in our reading for
these early weeks,
the movies first moved out into
what were called Nickelodeons.
They were storefronts
for the most part.
And admission was
a nickel, that's
where they were
called Nickelodeons.
And you sat in many
of these on benches
without backs,
next to strangers.
You didn't have private seats.
And you would sit in there and
see a series of short films.
But the fact that the
Nickelodeons emerged so quickly
is a mark of how popular a film
became, eve in its relatively
primitive early form.
And then, of course, within a
few years of the Nickelodeons
appearing, what else
began to happen?
Theaters made specially for
the showing of motion pictures
that were longer than
the early shorts,
because film began to expand its
length all through the period
from 1910 through 1920.
What's the great moment
when the feature film
is born in the United States?
1915.
Who's the director?
D.W. Griffith.
What's the film?
Birth of a Nation.
A very complicated example,
because it's content
is disturbing in some ways.
It's a very reactionary, and
in some respects racist film.
It absorbs and
carries forward what
we might think of as the
racial prejudices that
were very widespread
in American society
at the turn of the century,
and especially in the South.
From which Griffith
himself was a southerner,
he was born in the South.
And his film was deeply
influenced by a bestselling
novel called The Clansman, which
was a celebration of the Ku
Klux Klan.
So the content of
Birth of a Nation
is very unsettling
and disturbing.
And even when it
was first released
to the public-- to
great acclaim because it
expanded the possibilities of
movies in all kinds of ways.
From a technical standpoint it
is an astonishingly important
film.
And from a content standpoint
it's a very disturbing film.
It's a wonderful
reminder of the fact
that this progress
I'm describing to you
is not an unalloyed
triumphal story.
Even as the movies became
more technically complicated,
and more demanding, and
longer, and more interested
in character, they also
nonetheless carried
the lies, and prejudices,
and hierarchical assumptions
that were embedded in the
society from which they arose.
How could it be otherwise?
Every media form does this.
But it's important to make this
point as a way of reminding us
that the story we're telling
is not, in some simple sense,
just a kind of progress myth
in which we're celebrating
development and genius.
We're identifying and
locating something
more complicated than
that-- the process
whereby these cultural
myths, and these stories that
are drawn from
inherited older stories,
and from the lore of the society
more broadly, more generally,
are transformed into
this new medium.
And they have a tremendous
technical interest.
But very often they
also have a kind
of cultural or
sociological interest
of a negative kind in the
sense that what they reveal
are the prejudices, the lies,
the limitations of the society,
the mythologies that
sustain the society.
Again this is a matter
to which we'll return.
One of the deep cultural
functions of American movies,
especially, was to promulgate
a kind of mythology of America.
And we'll talk more
about this when
we reach certain genre
forms in the second segment
of the course.
I said something
earlier this morning
that I want to make
explicit, because I
think another way of qualifying
this triumphal story.
It's hard because I'm
enthusiastic about what
I'm looking at.
And there is some material
that's so exciting here.
In a way, what we're
watching is we're
watching the birth
of the movies.
We're watching the
discovery of the language
of cinema in these early films.
And that's why even though
from an artistic standpoint,
some of these shorts
are not very rich,
I hope they're
interesting enough--
that I've made them
interesting to you
from a historical standpoint.
If you look at them closely, you
can see the movies being born.
You can see a language, a
syntax for speaking in pictures,
for new visual language,
this new visual medium being
developed.
And if I have time
this evening, I'll
give you a few more
concrete examples of that.
But another way in which one
can qualify this apparently
triumphal story, it's
not a triumphal story
even though it is a story
of refinement, development,
and evolution of a
kind that involves
increasing complexity
and technical perfection,
technical mastery.
It's not merely that, or
not even primarily that.
It's very important to
recognize among other things,
as I implied this
afternoon, that not
all the possibilities that are
inherent in the nascent medium
are necessarily exploited in
a particular cultural moment.
Or maybe ever
exploited, depending
on how things develop.
That is to say.
I mentioned this afternoon how
for instance, when Edison first
conceive the apparatus before
it was actually invented,
of the motion picture projector,
and the motion picture camera.
His first idea was
that he would create
an item that would be a consumer
item-- what we would today
call a consumer
item-- that would
be sold to individual families.
And the field would
become an equivalent
or a kind of a photo
album, although it
would have motion it.
And as I suggested
this afternoon,
there's no reason why given
the nature of the technology
itself, that that vision
of how film might develop
was impossible.
In fact, it wasn't
impossible, it
was just incredibly
ahead of its time.
It took half a century
before something
like that actually became
available in society.
But there was no reason in
terms of the possibilities
of the technology that
that needed to happen.
What I'm calling
your attention to
is what is a very
widespread myth.
It's especially pernicious
and widespread at MIT.
For reasons that are obvious
and understandable we at MIT
love to believe the technology
will solve all problems.
The primary thing
I'm suggesting to you
is that the evolution
of the movies
that I want you to be
aware of, this process
of increasing complexity
and compression in which
the movies become a more
and more independent
form of expression.
In which the movies
begin to discover
the unique characteristics
of the motion picture camera
and of the environment of the
movie theater, that the movies
begin to explore.
Those qualities
in this new medium
that are unique and special.
That process is important, and
I want you to be aware of it.
But I don't want you to embrace
that principle to uncritically.
Because I want you to
recognize that the technology
itself does not
explain this process.
The processes explained
by cultural factors,
and social factors.
And even sometimes individual's
psychological factors.
What we're talking
about here is the myth
of technological determinism.
The myth that technology
drives culture.
The myth that a new invention
obliterates old inventions.
The truth is much more
complicated than that.
One of the most
remarkable things
about this evolutionary
process I've
been describing, as I said
earlier, is how swift it is.
How fast it is.
How we go from being
a mere novelty,
to becoming a significant
social form by 1910 or so.
And to becoming a virtually
universal aesthetic
and entertainment experience for
the majority of the population
in the country by 1920.
So when something
like 20 or 25 years
the movies go from being an
absolutely unknown or trivial
novelty, sharing space
with fortune tellers,
and strip shows in
the penny arcades,
to becoming not just an
embedded social form, but one
of the dominant economic
engines of the society,
employing tens of
thousands of people
in various direct and
ancillary positions.
And mobilizing virtually
the entire population
of the country in
a regular routine,
a habitual experience to which
they return again and again.
And because the audience is
returning again and again--
remember I said there's a
kind of symbiotic relation
between the audience and
the-- because the audience is
returning again and
again, what happens?
That's also one aspect
of the resources that
are available to the medium.
What begins then to develop
are forms of storytelling
that rely on the audience's
prior memory of other shows.
So that one thing that
emerges very quickly
is what we might
call a star system.
In which particular
actors become identified
with particular kinds of roles.
And audiences want to come
back to see those stars again
and again.
What also begins to happen
is the establishment
of a very rigorous
kind of genre system.
What's a genre?
A category of story.
The Western is a genre.
The detective story is a genre.
The elegy is a poetic genre.
And the typical, the
fundamental movie genres
begin to emerge
relatively early.
There's a Western
adventure story.
There's a historical spectacle.
There are certain forms of
urban, crime narrative that
became our detective and
crime films at a later stage.
And there emerge
especially certain forms
of satire and comedy.
So what genre system
begins to emerge as well?
And there are reasons of
course why this kind of thing
is useful to a mass
production system,
to an assembly line system.
If the same movie studio
makes seven Westerns,
they can use the same
horses again and again.
They can use the same set.
They can use the same hats.
And this in fact
happened, they might eve
be able to use the same clip
of film that shows a cattle
stampede in seven
different movies,
because nobody would
actually see it.
So economies of scale become
possible as the system
begins to regularize itself.
Once it stabilizes after that
period of imitation and patent
warfare.
And there's nothing
noble, or artistic,
or conscious about
this development.
That's part of what
makes it so remarkable.
And it puts out in touch
with the paradox that's
at the very heart of
what I hope to make
you aware of in this course.
It's a paradox that-- I guess
it animates my transition
many years ago now, from a
traditional literary scholar
into someone interested
in film and media.
And it's this paradox.
Based on what I've
been telling you
about this evolution, this
evolution of the medium,
of the film medium.
It's the paradox that
capitalist greed-- the crassest
of alliances between commerce
and modern technology--
might be the enabling conditions
of a complex narrative art.
Where does art come from?
It's not just about art though,
eve about sort of social.
Even if we forget the
question of art, and just
talk about the social
and cultural importance
of movie-going in
modern societies.
Leave out the question of
whether it's an aesthetically
valuable experience.
It's so central to
human experience,
remains so central
to human experience,
that there's a tremendous
paradox in this, that
the crassest of alliances
between commerce
and technology.
Nothing noble or
admirable about it.
Nobody's sitting
down thinking, I
want to make a new,
great medium for art.
Nonetheless this alliance
becomes the enabling conditions
for a complex form
of social experience
and of narrative art.
Well, that paradox at the
heart of a lot of what we'll
be looking at in this course.
I hope you'll keep
in mind as we go on.
I'd like to say a couple
of words, not too many,
a couple of words about
The Great Train Robbery.
The very first film
that you've seen.
The Great Train
Robbery is discussed
in some helpful detail in David
Cook's History of Narrative
Film.
And I urge you to look
closely at his account of it.
But I want to remind you
about a couple of highlights.
One is that although The
Great Train Robbery seems
very primitive to us, it's
important to realize that even
The Great Train Robbery
is already a refined text.
Most of the most
fundamental principles
of what we might call the
syntax or grammar of the movies
is already embedded in
The Great Train Robbery.
And what that means is
that the five or six year
period before that,
when there was
all this practicing with
non-narrative forms,
lies behind The
Great Train Robbery.
And what also lies behind
The Great Train Robbery
is this experience of audiences
going in first to the penny
arcades, then to the
Nickelodeons that
begin to open up by the
turn of the 20th century.
And becoming impatient with
repeated scenes that simply
show jokes, hoses going off
in people's faces, or trains
coming into a [INAUDIBLE].
After a while the
novelty wears off.
But of course, the people
who are making films
are also interested
in what they're doing.
You can feel especially, if you
look at D.W. Griffith's shorts,
and you will have
looked at two of them
in this course-- A Beast
at Bay, from last time,
and The Lonedale Operator, which
you'll see tonight before we
turn to the Keaton films.
And you'll see these are just
a sampling of his early work.
But if you look
closely at those where
you can feel Griffith's
own excitement
at discovering the
possibilities of the cinema.
In many cases Griffith is doing
some things with the camera,
doing some things with
the shaping of narrative
in cinema that had
never been done before.
And you can feel
his own excitement
at the possibilities of
this astonishing technology.
Well, the most important
discovery that The Great Train
Robbery shows us--
and again it seems
so obvious and so embedded
that we wouldn't even
think about it today.
We absorb these principles
so deeply into our DNA
that we don't even think.
We learn how to watch movies
in this way from the cradle,
in some ways.
Because by the time
most people today
are five or six
years old, they've
been subjected probably to more
audio/visual images than anyone
alive in 1900.
And we're just cognitively
different in terms
of our capacity to process
audio/visual information.
But imagine an audience
that's completely
illiterate in these
things, that has
to learn this system as the
system itself is evolving.
That's part of the excitement
of looking at these early films.
And the most important discovery
in The Great Train Robbery
is the discovery that the shot,
the single uncut shot of film,
however long it lasts, and
it's dependent on the decision
you make about when to edit it.
So it can go on for a long
time, or it can be very short.
And the length or
the shortness of cuts
also affects sort of the rhythm
of your experience in the film.
And this is something
that you can
see Griffith practicing
with, even as early as
A Beast at Bay.
If you think about the great
climax of the Beast at Bay
where you have the
woman being threatened,
but you also have this
race in the automobile
to try to get there on time.
And then the race to rescue
her by a variety of people.
What Griffith does is
he cuts back and forth.
He creates the principle
of parallel action.
And what he realized,
what he discovered
was that the audience will
recognize this kind of cutting
as showing you simultaneity.
Showing you things that are
going on at the same time.
What he discovered
were in a certain sense
how we would cognitively process
certain kinds of gestures
on film.
And what he
discovered of course,
is that if he cuts, if he edits
more quickly, if he creates
a fast rhythm he
creates excitement.
And what he began to
discover was something
that-- in later,
directors like Hitchcock
would carry, to an
almost evil pitch--
a capacity to manipulate and
control the audience's reaction
by the speed with which
particular images appear
or disappear.
So even at this early stage, you
could see Griffith discovering
important principles.
The most fundamental principle
in a Great Train Robbery,
which is not a Griffith
film, it proceeds Griffith,
is the discovery that the shot
is the basic unit of action.
Why is that a great discovery?
Well, if you think of
the movies as a device
or as a medium that
grows out of especially
a theatrical dispensation,
grows out of other things
as well, novels feed
into it, visual art
feeds into the movies.
But it's certainly true that
most of the major ways in which
directors first
conceive how to think
about the experience of what
the camera is looking at,
they would have been influenced
by their own experience
of theater.
And if you think
about it for a moment,
what you can see, even in The
Great Train Robbery, an impulse
to treat the camera
as a stable thing.
There are panning shots in which
the camera will go like this.
But the camera will not track.
It will not move back and
forth, or sideways, off,
in The Great Train Robbery.
That's a discovery that
Griffith is going to make
and will exploit.
And you can see it
in A Beast at Bay.
But in The Great Train Robbery,
we haven't got that far yet,
but what Edwin Porter did
discover was that the shot is
the basic unit of action.
And what this means
is it's not simply
what the camera sees, but
then how the shots are edited
afterwards that is so crucial.
So what he came
to understand was
that the making of any movie
is always a two-stage process.
There's the shooting
of the film,
and then there's the
editing the film.
And that itself is a
fundamental discovery.
But the idea that
the shot is the unit
of action instead of the scene
was hard for movie makers
to get.
What they would do, they
would set the camera up,
and then actors would walk
in front of the camera,
they would do what they had to
do, and they would walk off.
What's going on there?
They're conceiving of cinematic
space in theatrical terms.
As soon as the
camera is liberated,
taken off its
tripod, moved around
in some way, allowed to
backup or come close,
even allowed to move laterally.
What we're beginning to do was
to explore more systematically
what the camera's
unique features are.
How the theater is
different from the movies.
How certain effects are
possible in the movies
that would not be
possible in the theater.
When you watch the
Keaton films that you're
going to see tonight, watch
for the ways in which Keaton
repeatedly sets up
situations such that when
you see a particular gag of
his, a joke, what you realize
is that the joke could not
have happened in the theater.
It could not have been
told to you verbally.
The joke is visual.
The joke involves motion.
The joke involves a
recognition of the powers
of cinematic representation
to tell stories.
You'll see many examples of
this in the Keaton materials
that you'll be
looking at tonight.
So one of the very first
discoveries that's made
is the discovery that the shot
is the basic unit of action.
A second discovery
is the recognition
that you have to
cut between scenes.
You do you're editing
between shots.
Mostly what you do is
you let scenes play out,
even though you might
abruptly cut a scene
before the action is completed.
That's another
discovery that was
made, if you cut the
scene-- a person starts
to walk toward the door--
the first, earliest films,
they would show the person
walking all the way to the end,
walking out of the door.
Then, filmmakers
discovered, wait a minute.
There's a way of creating
a kind of quickness here.
Because if I show Thorburn
walking toward the door,
starting, and I cut.
And he knocks his glasses off.
And then I cut, and I wait
till he gets to the door,
and we see him leaving the door.
I don't have to watch
him take those 17 steps.
So what's been discovered
is a basic principle
of cinematic syntax.
It seems so obvious to
us, but of course it's
really a great discovery.
The properties of
the medium have
to be understood before you can
really begin to explain them.
And that's why I've
asked you to look
at some of these short films.
None of the short
films I've shown you
are completely without
some technical interest.
And even though of course
they're the only films
I'm showing you that I
wouldn't sort of make arguments
to defend them as works of art.
But I certainly would
make arguments for them
as technically
fascinating documents.
And I hope you'll look
at them in that light.
So the shot is a basic unit of
action cutting between scenes.
And a couple of other
things that I think
are important in The
Great Train Robbery.
One is that you can see in
The Great Train Robbery,
they're beginning to discover
the value of camera placement.
What happens when
you place the camera
in a particular position.
Especially if action's
coming toward the camera,
that you might not want to
place the camera directly
in front of the action
that's coming towards you,
that something happens if you
place it slightly forward it,
so it could see it
at a slight angle.
It creates a greater illusion
of depth in the image,
for example.
And it does other
kinds of things.
It let's the action
get closer to you
before the scene has to be cut.
So camera placement
is something that you
can see is beginning
to be learned,
beginning to be mastered in the
great trick in The Great Train
Robbery, or camera position.
And finally, one might
mention one other thing
that a again establishes
a principle that
then is continuous being
useful 50 or 75 years.
And that's the principle
of the process shot.
You can see in The
Great Train Robbery
that some effects have
been created by tricks.
That there's back
projection used in that.
It looks crude to us,
we can see through it.
But the early audiences would
not have recognized that.
We're so used to location
filming that we can pick out--
we today can see through the
process shots of earlier films.
This in fact damages
some of Hitchcock's films
very badly today.
Because Hitchcock
used a lot of process
shot effects in his films.
When he made them the
audiences were used to it.
There was a convention
of film going.
Today because cameras are so
much more mobile and light,
and so much has been
learned about how
to-- even about filming
in low light and so forth.
That there's much less
use of process shots.
A new kind of process
shot, I suppose,
is emerging with
digital animation.
And one could say
it's sort of a return
to the idea of manipulating
the image in illegitimate ways.
But in The Great
Train Robbery we
can even see the beginnings
of the use of process shots.
Of recognizing that you can
create effects in the movies
that are unique and special,
that no other medium
would allow you to do.
And what's embedded
there is science fiction.
What's embedded they
are all the kinds
of imaginative, not
just science fictional.
All the kinds of
imaginative movies
that have been made
that maybe take you
inside people's
nightmares or dreams.
Where what the film
is showing you now--
what is embedded in
that process shot?
Even more fully embedded in
Melies', the French director's
films, like Trip to the
Moon, where he explicitly
goes into a realm of fantasy.
It's not only that the film is
the most profoundly realistic
medium that was ever invented.
It may also be the
most expressive medium
for the rendering of
non-realistic states
of dream, of
nightmare, of fantasy.
Because of the freedom that
the film medium allows.
And even these
implications are at least
embedded in the use of the
process shots in Porter's The
Great Train Robbery.
The other short
that you're going
to see tonight that
is not by Keaton
is called The Lonedale Operator.
It was made in 1911.
In a way it's the most
advanced film of its time.
And what I hope
when you look at it,
you'll watch especially
for how much more complex
it is than, let's say,
The Great Train Robbery.
And there'll be a kind of
small measure of this Fred Ott
principle that I've
been talking about.
Let me mention a couple of
things about The Lonedale
Operator.
Between 1907 and
1911, most films
consisted of no more
than 24 separate shots.
Between 1908 and 1913,
led by D.W. Griffith
and his company, The
Biograph Company,
many more shots were introduced
into a single reel of film.
And in The Lonedale
Operator, there
are 98 shots, six
intertitles, one main title,
and two written inserts.
All within a 17 minutely length.
But think of just the
access of complexity
that has occurred just
in less than 10 years.
It's such a complicated
film that one
of the things we realized,
even looking at it if we look
closely is that it
actually required
a kind of attentiveness
that earlier films did not.
As filmmakers began
to make these things,
and began to make
them longer, and began
to make them more complicated.
They realized that
they couldn't just
bring the camera out
and start shooting.
They began to develop
the formal rationalizing
strategies that led to
the making of movies
as we understand them.
There was a four day
shooting schedule created
for The Lonedale Operator.
It was one of the first
films to have this format.
And of course it's
the format that
is followed today with
virtually every film
in different aspects.
And this also required a
preplanned shooting script.
They had to preplan all of their
shooting, all of their shots,
all of their camera angles.
They need a shooting
script, a written script.
Films didn't have
written scripts at first,
but Lonedale did.
And it also required
in order for them
to make their schedule,
out of order shooting.
That is to say they had to
shoot certain things not
in the sequential order.
And that's one of the most
basic principles of filmmaking.
Because once you
set up the camera
for a shot of a
particular environment,
if that environment shows
up later in the film,
it's unbelievably more
expensive and time consuming
to reconstitute that whole set.
So almost all films
to this very day
are still shot out
of sequence in order
to maximize the time you have,
in order to work at your most
efficient.
It's not an efficient
way to make a movie
to shoot it
sequentially, to follow
the to follow the script in
its chronological sequence.
And The Lonedale
Operator is maybe
the first film have to
have all of these features
that we would associate with
a modern or contemporary film.
You might notice in it's an
immensely complex films, even
in terms of its content.
And I won't talk about that
much now except to say this,
watch the way in
which the film tries
to deal with what we might
call hierarchies of gender.
The film is partly about how
a woman takes on a man's job.
I think it's guess it's
her father, isn't it?
Her father is ill.
And she has to take over
running the train station.
And so there's a
certain sense in which
one of the things that's
dramatized socially
is a woman moving into
a masculine realm.
Taking on a role that's
more aggressive than
is appropriate for the
gender ideologies that
are dominant at the end of
the 19th century in the United
States.
But the film was pretty
clever about this,
like many such popular texts.
Because although it does grant
this woman a certain kind
of masculine authority
and competence,
it also has other things in
the film that balance that.
That remind us that she is
still nonetheless a weak vessel.
That she is still
a damsel in stress
like the typical Victorian
construction of women.
And what you can see is
that the movie exhibits
an anxiety about gender roles
that's also an anxiety that's
resident in the society itself.
And I won't talk
more about this now.
We will develop this
aspect of the movies
as a reflection of social
anxieties and social problems
as the course goes on.
But I do want to
call your attention
to certain technical things that
you can watch for, to at least
one technical item in the film.
It contains what might
be called rhyming scenes.
In which at one
point in the film
you'll see a sequence of
scenes in a particular shot.
And then, later in the film,
almost exactly the same shot
will reappear.
And the effect of
this, of course,
is to create a
sense of coherence
and a sense of familiarity
in the audience.
It's actually a very
subtle and careful strategy
that Griffith himself devised.
It creates a kind of continuity
and clarity to the whole film.
Watch, for example, how the
doorway to the Lonedale station
is photographed when
you first see it.
How this image anchors the
film's spatial relationships.
And how the film has a certain
trajectory of movement that is
repeated as the film goes on.
So that for example,
early in the film,
we see the heroine
go from the exterior
to the interior of
the ticket office,
and then to the inner office
of the telegraph operator.
We see her do this.
And then, this sets up a basic
location and basic action
for the entire film.
It's as if what happens
in that moment sets up,
creates a familiarity
for the audience with it,
the geography of the movie.
Because a lot of
the action then will
depend on our understanding
about geography.
And then there at least four
different times that Griffith
repeats that basic three-shot
trajectory, from the exterior
to the interior of
the ticket office,
and then to the inner office
of the telegraph operator.
It happens four
times in the film.
So the film has a kind
of visual coherence.
By the time you come to it
the third or fourth time,
it's as if you were intimate
with the physical geography
of the movie.
This is actually a
structural feature
that is easy to miss it, but
it's actually very artful.
And we can see it's a mark of
how far film has come, even
by 1911, that this
level of attentiveness
is available to us in the film.
There's much more that could
be said about The Lonedale
Operator, but I will leave
it to your intelligence
and your attentiveness to
try to pick out more things.
And again we're only talking
about a 17-minute film.
Well, Buster Keaton's career
could be said, in some degree,
to enact in small the larger
processes I've been describing.
He comes into film late.
And in fact, if we were working
perfectly chronologically
in terms of when Chaplin
became a director,
he would precede Keaton.
But I've organized
the film according
to the dates of
the feature films,
and the general is much
of a decade earlier
than modern times.
Which is the last,
quote, "silent film."
It's not really a
silent film, but it's
the last silent film in a
deep sense that was ever made.
It was made in the
sound era, in 1936.
And next week we'll talk more
about the implications of that,
and why that was a very daring
thing for Chaplin to do.
Something like almost a decade
after the advent of sound
he made a movie that essentially
had no dialogue in it.
So Keaton came a little later.
Keaton comes into movie making a
little few years after Chaplin.
But his career has a
similar trajectory.
He began his career
in legitimate theater,
in vaudeville and on
the performance circuit.
He was an Acrobat
from a very young age,
from the age of two or three
was in his parents stage act.
And in fact, he learned a
lot of his acrobatic feats
on his parents stage act.
One very famous passage in his--
his father used to take him,
he was just a young
kid, three or four years
old, five years old, he
would take him by his legs
and swing him back
and forth, like this.
He had very long hair.
And he would sweep the
floor with his hair.
And then, swing him
two or three times--
this would happen life--
he would swing it like this
and let him go.
And the kid, five years old,
would fly against the wall
and fall down.
It would look terrible.
And later in his life,
Keaton talked about this.
There were actually
some cities in which
the societies the prevention
of cruelty to children came in,
shut down the act, wouldn't
allow the act to go on.
Not stupid, because his
father was a drunkard
and sometimes performed drunk.
And Keaton was
sometimes injured.
He was also injured when he
made his own movies, because he
was such a daring acrobat.
And Keaton recounts that when he
first began to perform in this,
he would make faces, faces that
indicated pain, or happiness,
or relief, when his father
was manipulating this way.
But he found that the audience
responded much more comically,
much more immediately,
if he just
kept his face expressionless.
And that's where
they're developed,
the probably mistaken label
for Keaton, of the great stone
face.
And in his films
very often you'll
see this young man facing
monumental catastrophe.
His face would
look out at things
without ever
changing expression,
and there is something
kind of comical about that.
You'll see some examples
of this in the general.
Well, you'll see in
the two short films
that Keaton began to
make that he enters film
at already a relatively
sophisticated time.
And the shorts I'm
asking you to look at
are very interesting, remarkable
films in their own way.
And one of the
things they teach us,
and one of the reasons I want
you look closely at Keaton
is they show us yet again
another aspect of what
I mean when I talk
about the Fred Ott
principle, this development
of evolution and increasing
complexity.
Because if you look at Cops,
or if you look at One Week,
what you will see Keaton
doing in those films
is learning how to
link jokes together
in some sort of a coherent way.
And there are wonderful coherent
sequences in these films.
But still one doesn't
feel that there's
a real character in
them, that there's
a sustained, coherent, fictional
universe being dramatized.
Maybe in Cops one
does feel this.
This much more sort of
textual coherence in Cops.
But what we can
see Keaton doing is
beginning to move from
the idea of a single joke
to a sequence of jokes.
And then, by the time
we get to the general,
moving from a single joke
to a sequence of jokes
to a sustained narrative,
which incorporates
within it various
kinds of comical jokes,
and also sequence jokes.
Because Keaton's best jokes
are not single jokes at all,
they're one liners, but the joke
will be told again and again.
Or really, what will happen
is he will do something,
and you'll think how could.
And then, the next step will
top what he's done before.
Then, the next step will top.
You think that he
got to a point where
it'd be impossible to add
another comic complication
to what he's done when
he, of course, does it.
And this becomes one of the deep
principles of Keaton's comedy.
There are numerous examples
of it in both the two shorts,
and in the longer
film The General.
But let me mention an
example from The General.
Very early in The
General, there's
a sequence-- it's probably the
quintessential Keaton sequence,
and I won't go into such detail
as to spoil the film for you.
But let me just say,
it involves a cannon,
and it involves Keaton.
Keaton plays the engineer of
a locomotive, a locomotive
engineer.
The general of the title
is not a military general,
it's a locomotive,
the locomotive
is called the General.
And the film recounts a
historically true story
of a time when the
Union Army came
into Confederate territory, and
stole a locomotive belonging
to the Confederacy.
And Keaton, in a comic
vein retells this story.
When you watch this
cannon sequence,
you'll see exactly what I mean.
And this sequences at the
heart of James Agee's essay
on the silent film comedy.
When you read that essay,
you'll see even more clearly
what I mean by a trajectory
joke or a sequence joke.
Which builds, and
builds, and builds,
and keeps topping itself.
Well, this cannon sequence
is a perfect example of that.
And it's a perfect
example of it not only
because we see the joke getting
more complicated as it goes on,
but as the joke becomes more
complicated something else
happens.
The joke becomes
more than a joke,
it becomes a kind of
comment on experience.
It becomes a kind of comment
on what life is like.
That is to say, we
move from something
that simply makes us
smile to something that
makes us think about
the world, that
comments on the
world, that imagines
the world in a coherent way.
I'll try to be more explicit
about this in a moment.
So in Keaton's career, we see
him doing astonishing things
as an Acrobat.
And we would admire him just
for his acrobatic performances
in these films.
In The General for
example, the way
in which when he's piloting
his locomotive, chasing
the people who have stolen
his original locomotive, how
he's the only one on the train.
And he crawls all
over the train.
While the train is running he'll
crawl up to the front of it.
He'll run to the back of
it to put more fuel in.
And also, you can see this stuff
happening, really happening.
It's not faked in any
way, because there's
a camera following the
train as it's moving.
You can see it's really
moving, because you can see it.
You can see it
moving on the track,
and you can see the
world behind it.
And you can tell that Keaton
is not taking these effects.
Well, this cannon sequence
is a sublimely rich example
of this complex process
I've been describing.
And it has to do
in part with what
I call the multiplicity
principle, Which
I will define in a moment.
So we see Keaton as
an acrobat actor.
As a man, much
more than Chaplin,
interested in the technology of
motion pictures, and of cinema.
And you'll see a
couple of examples
in the films you going
to look at tonight
in which we see Keaton exploring
in a somewhat systematic way
the nature of the illusion
of motion pictures.
There's one remarkable
comical moment in One Week.
In which the heroine
gets into a bathtub,
and it looks like she's
sitting in the bathtub.
She's starting to
get up, and looks
like you're actually about to
see some unmentionable parts
of her body.
And just as that's
about to happen,
a hand comes in front of
the camera and blocks you.
And it's actually a very
disturbing moment in a way,
because it interrupts
the narrative flow.
It's an intervention
from the outside.
Whose hand did it?
It's not a character
in the film.
It's the director's.
Very bold moment,
because what it
does is it reminds you of
the film as an artifact.
It reminds you that the
film is an artifact.
In other words, it's a
moment of self-reflexiveness
self-consciousness that you
would never seen a Chaplin
film, but shows Keaton's
astonishing interest
in the technology
of motion pictures.
I had many examples that
Greg and I had ready,
but I don't have
time to show to you.
Maybe you could put up, while
I'm talking, The Playhouse.
One of his most famous
examples of this
is a film called The Playhouse,
in which he ends up playing
every role in the movie.
And the way he did was
incredibly interesting.
He would shoot the film,
but he put masking tape
over the lens of the camera.
And only one little, tiny
part of the lens of the camera
was what would expose the film.
And he would shoot that, then
he would rewind the film.
And then, if he were over in
this corner for that shot,
then he'd move over, and
sit in the other corner.
He'd put a new kind of tape
on the camera, film it again.
And the film you're going
to see will show this.
And you can see,
they're all Buster.
Again what it shows
is he's a technician.
He's interested in the
technology of the motion
picture camera, and what kinds
of manipulations are possible.
He's the conductor.
As it turns out, he's
going to also end up
being the only person
in the audience.
And then finally, what
I've already implied
is that Keaton's jokes
and his technical interest
also end up making him a
metaphysician, a philosopher,
an artist.
Now Keaton himself could never
articulate his own ambitions
in this way.
If you said, Mr. Keaton, your
vision of the absurd universe
is more complex and rich
than Jean-Paul Sartre.
As in fact, it is incidentally.
He would laugh.
He wouldn't even understand
what you were talking about.
Not only because he'd never read
Sartre, since he died before.
He was alive live when
Sartre was alive, actually.
But the universe that he
projects has a kind of content
or a meaning that's a
function of how intelligent he
is about exploiting his medium,
and telling his stories,
as if his jokes express a vision
of life, a sense of experience.
What you're looking at is
sort of minor Keaton here,
but it shows his
technical interest.
So let me explain
what I mean basically
by the multiplicity principle.
This process of
accretion and complexity
I've described-- at a certain
point you get to a point
where what began as a gag or
as a mere entertainment takes
on a density or a texture
that makes you think, wait
a second, the vision
of experience that's
projected in this text is
intrinsically interesting.
That is to say, there's
an understanding of life
that's embedded in the story.
When you reach the point
where the text itself embodies
some sort of
understanding of life,
and an understanding of life
that's coherently presented,
powerfully presented,
what you're looking at
is what I call art.
You might just call it more
intelligent entertainment.
But this is a way
of distinguishing
between entertainment and art.
At which there's a
certain point at which
entertainment becomes
so complicated
that it's more than
mere entertainment.
When does that occur?
Well, one way to
tell when it occurs
is to watch for I call the
multiplicity principle.
When events in the film
play more than one function,
do more than one job.
When they forward the story,
but also declare for character.
When they make you laugh, but
also express a vision of life.
And at the same time are
consistent with the character's
psychological nature.
That multiplicity, that
density, that texture
is what we associate
with works of art.
A bad example would
be you are familiar,
I hope, with the kind
of bad soap opera
line in which a character
comes into something like this,
oh, hello, John, my
long-lost brother who
just got out of
the insane asylum
after 15 years of unfair misery.
What's wrong with that line?
Why is that a stupid line?
Although we hear
them all the time.
What's wrong with it?
AUDIENCE: Sounds excessive,
and awkward exposition.
DAVID THORBURN: It's
very awkward exposition,
but why is it so awkward?
What makes it so awkward?
Its intention is clear.
It wants to present
information to the audience.
But in order to do that,
what has it violated?
AUDIENCE: It ceases to
be something that follows
the nature of the character.
DAVID THORBURN: It ceases
to be something that
honors the character's nature.
Exactly right.
That's a very good answer.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Michael.
DAVID THORBURN: Michael.
Thanks, Michael.
That's very good.
I want to give information
to the audience.
In order to do that I'll
compromise the character's
basic nature.
No sister talking to a brother
would recount the brother's
history to the brother.
That just wouldn't happen.
So in order to
accomplish one task,
the text has compromised
itself on another task.
But imagine a story in which
this information emerges
in dramatic ways.
Two characters are talking,
and Mary says to John,
oh, John, my brother's
coming back from the asylum.
And she says, really?
I didn't even know
he was in the asylum.
And Mary pulls back
and says, I don't
know if I should tell you.
OK.
So we have a dramatic
scene, in which
the information that the
audience is supposed to have
is presented in a way
that maybe tells us
something about Mary's nature.
And maybe tells us something
about John's nature.
That is multiplicity.
That's what I mean by the
multiplicity principle.
You will see many,
many instances
of what I'm calling the
multiplicity principle
in Keaton's work.
And you will especially see it
in these astonishing, repeated
sequences, and I'm talking now
in a way about The General,
in which we see the Keaton hero.
Who sort of is steadfast
but also a muddler.
He keeps doing the same things.
They're not really
likely to help them.
And then, he gets
help from the outside.
Keaton's jokes repeatedly
depend upon the idea of accident
in a certain way.
And I'll come back
to that in a second.
So think about the multiplicity
principle, the difference
between entertainment and art.
Again this is a principle
I'll come back to, and try
to illustrate with greater
concreteness and greater
leisure in later lectures.
But I want you to be
aware of these issues.
So The General can be understood
as a kind of culminating text
in at least two ways.
It's a culmination
of Keaton's career.
That is to say the
jokes and gags that
are enacted in the film recall
many earlier Keaton films.
And the basic character
of The General
is the basic character
of the Keaton hero.
A steadfast,
unremarkable young man
who perseveres in the face
of catastrophic difficulties
with mostly comic expectations,
very small expectations
of success.
Who often models through
almost despite himself.
But I say, almost
despite himself.
And this is where the complexity
of Keaton's vision of life
comes in.
Why I'm saying that Keaton moves
from being merely a jokester,
or being merely a
great entertainer,
to being an artist.
His jokes embody an idea
of what experience is like,
and it's a very powerful,
mordant, mature idea
of experience.
Because what happens again,
and again in the small jokes,
the sequence jokes
in Keaton's work,
especially in The General,
and in the larger film, what
happens again, and
again, is an adventure
in which a steadfast,
relentless, young, hero
does everything he can
to accomplish his goal.
And it's obvious that
he's up against forces
far beyond himself,
that he could never--
there's an unbelievable
miss mismatch
between this minuscule,
tiny, figure and his powers,
and the forces he's
fighting against.
His one Keaton film
called The Navigator,
in which the Keaton
character-- even more
than with the locomotive
in The General--
has to navigate an ocean liner.
And he's alone on
the ocean liner.
And you see running up and
down into the engine room,
back up to the bridge,
running all over the ocean
liner in great difficulties.
There's a wonderful film,
late film made in 1928,
just his last silent film
called Steamboat Bill
Jr. In which he dramatizes
an astonishing hurricane.
And a long, extended
sequence in which
we see him trying to
escape the hurricane,
trying to contend against
this natural force that's
so gigantic.
So The General is a
culmination in the sense
that it gives us another
version, and the richest
version so far of the adventures
of this kind of Keaton hero.
But what makes it metaphysical
or philosophically
interesting is that what
this joke repeatedly does,
and what the structure
of the whole film
repeatedly says is something
like this, we get through,
we make it through life.
We get through life mostly
not because of anything
we've done but
because of accident.
We live in a
contingent universe.
The idea of contingency is at
the heart of Keaton's jokes.
We could call them
jokes about contingency.
The word contingent
is interesting.
Remember it means libel,
but not certain to occur.
It means possible.
It means dependent upon,
subject to, conditioned by.
In law you can say that
something that is contingent
is dependent for its effect on
something that may or may not
occur.
As in a contingent
estate or legacy.
In logic, the same thing,
dependent upon some condition,
or upon the truth
of something else.
Not true a priori,
not necessary.
So what Keaton's
jokes constantly do
is they show us two things.
They show us a world in
which human agency matters.
Because if this
should schmendrick
didn't keep-- that's a
Jewish word for schlemazel,
clown-- If this schmendrick
did not keep on so steadfastly,
he wouldn't survive.
But he's keeping on
so steadfastly still
wouldn't make him
survive if there weren't
the intervention of
mere accidents, stuff
he has no control over.
This one magnificent moment
in One Week, for example,
where he's standing at a certain
place, and the house behind him
falls down.
And he's happens,
just by accident,
to be standing by the open
window, and the house falls,
so he doesn't get hurt.
He used this joke more
than once in other films
because it's such a great one.
But it's a perfect
example of what
I mean, a partial
example of what I mean.
Because he is not responsible
for the fact that he escaped.
On the other hand,
because he was
trying to get away
from difficulties,
maybe he was in that
particular position
because of acts of his own.
So what this joke and
vision says about the world
is something that's true.
We all love the idea
that we've gotten
to where we are by our own acts,
by our own conscious control.
The truth of the
matter is that life is
much more contingent than that.
It's partly accident,
it's partly luck.
And something deeper than that.
Keaton's vision
of the universe is
one which suggests that while
the universe may screw you up
sometimes, it won't
always do that.
The universe in Keaton's
world is not angry at us,
it's indifferent to us.
It doesn't give a damn about us.
It's not aware of us.
It's too big for us.
You can't come away
from Keaton's films
without a simultaneous sense on
the importance of human action,
of human agency.
But also of the inadequacy
Of how contingent every
experience, every adventure,
every personality is.
And that and that meaning,
that idea of the world
is a profound one, I think.
So that even though
Keaton is telling a joke,
embedded in the joke is a kind
of interpretation of life.
And embedded in the film is a
kind of interpretation of life.
When you're looking
at The General,
I think you will see multiple
examples of this kind of thing.
Let me say one last thing,
I haven't mentioned anything
about the structure of the film,
I'm a little out of the way
there.
Watch how the film
is structured.
It's a much more
complex variation
on what I said about
Lonedale Operator.
The film begins with
him going up the track.
And then, the second
half of the film
has him going back
down the track.
You may not be aware
of it, but actually
the film in a certain sense
has its tail its mouth.
When he goes up the track, he
has a series of adventures.
When he comes back
down, he has a series
of adventures that in a
certain sense replicate what's
happened before.
The film mirrors itself
in a way, repeats itself.
It's incredibly
elegant structure.
And the elegance
of the structure
reminds us also--
its own way, also
reminds us of this
principle of contingency
that's at the heart of
Keaton's vision of the world.
Let me conclude by reminding
you again what I said earlier.
When I call Keaton
a philosopher,
and a metaphysician and a
wise person about the world,
I do not at all mean
to suggest that if ask
Keaton to explain how we
thought about the world
he could do this.
That that's the
job of professors
and literary and film critics.
What I'm saying to
you is that Keaton,
like many great artists,
had an intuitive
understanding of the world.
Which he expressed with
greater, and greater complexity
in the medium of the cinema.
And in The General, we
have what is ultimately
a culminating instance of that.
One last point about the film
as a culminating example.
It's not just the culmination
of Keaton's career.
It's a culmination of
silent film as a whole.
Keaton would have
expected his audience
to recognize the degree
to which this film was
a parity or a mockery of
famous historical films made
by D.W. Griffith.
It puts down the pretentiousness
and the martial valor
that's celebrated in so many
of the historical spectacles
that Griffith and
other serious directors
were making at the time.
And it also goes
back in a certain way
to the very roots of film.
What was the very
first narrative film?
Or one of the very first?
Also a film about
a train robbery,
called The Great Train Robbery.
Well, this is about
a train robbery, too.
And who is the central
character in this one?
Really, a train is
the central object,
the central-- more
interesting in some
ways than the character himself.
And there are many other ways
in which the particular features
of the general allude to,
and in some sense summarize,
the history of silent film.
And all of the original audience
coming to see The General
would have been, of course
alert to these connections.
Would have been literate
in these connections.
Wouldn't have needed
footnotes or professors
to tell them about it.
Because they would have
lived through the history.
They would have been through
the history of the previous 20
years.
They would have seen
other Keaton films.
They would have
seen D.W. Griffith.
They would have the
history of the medium
of movies in their
heads when they sat down
to watch The General.
So that's another way
in which The General is
a profoundly culminating text.